do you remember the hardest time you've
ever laughed
um
such a serious face
the hardest i've ever laughed
so basically
the happiest i ever was
nothing comes to mind
can can you remember anything difficult
or traumatic
i have a lot to sort through
you smile when you're looking for that
one oh yes
oh yes there has been some trouble
um
yeah i i you know i laugh a lot with my
girlfriend it's it's pretty much
non-stop
um i'm not going to give examples
because clearly it's just in our bubble
um
but
there's so many things that i i can't
even
i can't even give us a
well you told me i don't even i can't
even say that word i wrote didn't i no i
didn't wasn't there something on the
podcast about squirts or something
yes um
i know that's another bubble bit it's an
in love but it is
it's a it's a it is a relationship but
how did it go we were uh
talking about
i feel like going what what happened
just right over there could just ask her
yeah what what happened
well we were talking about
oh yeah
and then we laughed and laughed